hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new apple watch series 7 and today
we will compare it to the series 4 the
series 5 and the series 6 and show you
guys every single difference and then
answer the main question and that is if
it's worth upgrading so let's go ahead
and get this unboxed now just so you
guys know i actually did not upgrade to
the series six i didn't think it was
worth it so i'm very curious if it's
gonna be worth upgrading this year and i
did end up getting the new green color i
think that's probably the most
significant new one before i get out of
the box i do want to mention the charger
this time for the first time we are
actually getting a usb type-c charger
and you are going to need to use this
charger with usbc and at least a 5 watt
brick if you want the new faster
charging and now let's get this new
watch out of here
we'll check out the new green color and
it's crazy that in this lighting this
green almost looks like a graphite or a
black i'm not sure what you guys are
seeing through the camera but it's a
very dark green i'm gonna get the setup
process going and then we're gonna
compare the case differences because
holding it in the hand didn't seem to be
that different while the seven is
sinking let's compare all the exterior
differences let's start out with the
sensors series five and four are
identical and if we flip around series
seven and series 6 you guys could see
that they are both identical apple has
not changed anything with these bottom
sensors the big change actually came in
from the series 5 to the series 6.
that's because we got the blood oxygen
monitoring sensors built in as you guys
can see now the series 6 5 and 4 all
have identical cases so let's go ahead
and move these off to the side and we
will compare all of the differences that
we finally have with an updated case on
the series 7. starting off with the
crown side the layout looks identical
the crown doesn't look different at all
our microphone hole looks identical the
button looks identical and flipping over
to the opposite side we notice our first
change and that is the speaker girl
instead of two separate ones we have a
single speaker grill that is slightly
shorter than before now the next
difference is actually facing me right
now it's very hard to see and that is
the diagnostic port that is built in for
a physical connection hidden where your
strap goes in and with the series 7 that
is now completely gone apple is now
using a 60 gigahertz wireless data
transfer technology in order to diagnose
apple watches and that's likely what
they're gonna do with future wireless
mac save data transfer when the iphone
goes portless as for the rest of the
differences you guys could see now that
i stacked them next to each other that
the series seven is actually taller so
apple did have to get new molds to
create this new apple watch now apple
mentioned that the series 7 is actually
the most curved apple watch but looking
at them it's really hard to notice the
difference but one thing i do notice is
that the glass actually is larger on the
top and there's less frame visible for
that larger display now let's compare
the display and the rest of the
differences i have all four on my arm
this is not very comfortable i think
i've ever done this but the good thing
is we're not going to keep the series 4
on here for long and that is because it
is almost identical to the series 5. the
biggest difference is the fact that it
does not have the always on display as
you guys could tell the screen turns off
completely compared to the rest of
lineup that keeps the display on now
with that uh the series 5 6 and 7 also
have a compass built-in which is series
4 doesn't and they all have 32 gigabytes
of storage which the series 4 doesn't
other than that the 5 is identical to
the four so i can remove this get my arm
a little bit more comfortable now so
it's not going to be cutting off all my
circulation and let's keep going on with
our comparison now before we go over the
other hardware differences what i want
to cover are the displays now last year
as i mentioned i did not upgrade from
the 5 to the 6 because apple's claim of
having a brighter always on display
which was my biggest complaint about the
5 wasn't really that huge at least
indoors but this year they said that the
7 is 70 brighter indoors and you guys
let me know what do you think what are
you guys seeing right now like to me
personally i see that the six is just
slightly brighter than five not enough
to make a difference but the seven is
noticeably brighter than both the six
and the five now i'm also gonna test the
brightness outdoors or when it's really
bright and that's where the six change
more so from the five so i'm opening up
my flashlight right here which is gonna
simulate brighter lighting and what do
you guys see um right now i definitely
see that the six is brighter than the
five we have a bigger difference now
but the seven and the six look identical
as far as brightness so outdoors they're
always on display there will be no
difference from the 6 but a fairly
decent one from the 5. now as far as
when the screens are on we have no
differences they're all 1000 nit maximum
brightness and that is the same case for
the series 4 the se and even the series
3 when you're looking at your watch when
the screen is active they are all
identical now there are six changes with
the new series seven over the series six
but before i tell you guys those let's
cover what changed from the five to the
six that way i can get this off my wrist
and we can compare the newest ones in my
opinion the biggest difference is the
blood oxygen sensor so that's built into
the series six and of course the series
seven also gets that and the 5 does not
have that so if you're somebody that
struggles with that or you have
allergies or other reasons to test it
out this could be a massive difference
the next hardware change is the
always-on altimeter so it's working in
the background giving you better
accuracy for times when you're hiking or
doing other activities when you have a
change in elevation so you do not get
that with the series five but you do
with the six and seven the series five
also doesn't support five gigahertz
wi-fi so when you're doing updates
transfers it is slower with the 2.4
gigahertz and it also has a slower s5
chip the series 6 is 20 faster for the
processor than the series 5 but the
series 7 actually pretty much just has a
renamed s6 chip with a couple tweaks
with the display so the processor in the
7 is the same the series 5 is a little
bit slower but personally using the 5 i
have had no complaints in terms of
performance and the last hardware
difference between the 5 and the 6 as
well as the 7 is the ultra wideband u1
chip which allows you to be able to find
other items or other items to be able to
accurately connect to the watch now that
could be used for finding say your apple
tags and for guidance but for some
reason apple has not yet enabled that in
the series 6 or the series 7 so that
could be something that in the future
would matter but for now with the find
my app you don't get that guidance yet
that u1 chip is not activated and then
maybe in the future you can unlock your
car or maybe if you have a smart lock at
your house but for now that u1 chip
isn't being used and with that there are
a ton of similarities between the series
5 and the 6 and of course with that the
series 7. they all have ecg testing
second generation heart rate sensors
compass and accelerometers fall
detection 50 meters of water resistance
32 gigs of storage updated speakers and
microphones the noise sensing app the w3
chip and bluetooth 5.0 so all those
features apply to the six and the seven
so i can take the series five off and
now let's actually talk about the six
changes with the series seven now we
somewhat covered the first two
differences and that is the new charger
that uses usb type c for one and the
second one is the 33
faster charging and that is thanks to
that usbc connection and better coils
that are built into the watch now apple
says eight minutes of charging is enough
to go through an eight hours of sleep
tracking so that is really nice for that
specific scenario number three is the 50
thicker glass which led apple to say
that this is the most durable apple
watch ever made and with that we have
number four which is the new ip6x
dust resistance rating that comes with
that durability now apple has actually
never given a dust rating for the apple
watch so this year they paid for that
certification so we're not entirely sure
if that dust resistance is just because
the new display or just because they
finally tested it now number five and
six are much more significant and that's
what i care about most likely you do as
well number five is the new qrt keyboard
so with all past apple watches series 6
5 4 and previous if you want to write
something out you literally have to draw
it
on the screen hope you do correctly if
you don't sometimes it would just be off
and then it's just a really really slow
painful process so i would typically
just use voice recognition but in cases
where it's very loud or it's very quiet
you don't want to be talking to your
watch you would have to rely on writing
one character at a time so that is very
slow now we have the full qrt keyboard
you can actually swipe between the
letters and it will use prediction to
give you accurate results so i can
actually write out a sentence like this
fairly quickly now as i was doing this
you guys could see that i made some
mistakes and it will actually learn how
you swipe and increase accuracy but i
will have to actually test this out and
see is this actually feasible for real
world use and am i actually going to
want to use it or just still try to rely
on
voice dictation so we'll talk about that
in our full review and difference number
six is the new display and we're gonna
go through this right now and see all of
the differences and how much that
actually matters because apple is really
pushing this upgrade now right here with
the meridian watch face you guys could
see the difference in the bezel the
bezel is a lot slimmer the series 6 and
5 and 4 those are 44 millimeter watches
this one right here is a 45 millimeter
so it's not a huge difference but apple
is using the curve of the display to
refract the light and make some of that
screen which actually doesn't take up as
much of the room because it's only
laminated to the flat part but it makes
it kind of curve to the edge now this is
most visible with the new contour watch
face that is exclusive
to the series 7 where we have all of our
numbers that are just kind of right
there curved towards the edge and as i
scroll through you guys can see it
highlights certain parts of them and it
still leaves a little bit of room for my
silent mode right there at the top as
you guys could see but with that said
looking at it i do see that it's
slightly curved if i'm looking from the
side but looking from the top it doesn't
look
like that much of a difference so let's
go ahead and switch to a different watch
face right here you guys can see the new
portrait watch face which it'll take
certain photos and actually put the time
right behind it so i have vadim on here
it's actually pretty tricky to find one
that works properly the series 6 also
supports portrait here i just have a
regular photo open but you guys could
see the difference in that bezel once
again
and to my eyes i expected a bigger
difference in screen size judging off of
their photos and images that they have
on their website of course they want to
maximize that difference to get you to
upgrade but right now i'm not seeing
that big of a difference now there is
one more watch face that is exclusive to
the new series seven so right here we
see the modular duo below i have the
portraits and real time which does come
to the series six but let's go ahead and
add this modular duo which has a lot of
info available so here's how that
modular duo looks we have two large wide
complications so here i have apple
stocks open compared to just the regular
module that is available for the series
six and the five here we just get a
little bit info we don't get that nice
graph if you're into stocks of course
you still have the modular available for
the series seven
and this is basically the difference
that you get with that larger display
you see that everything's slightly
larger slightly closer to the corners of
the screen but in my opinion the
difference isn't that significant maybe
you do really care about having it
slightly larger but it's not a reason
that i personally would upgrade just for
that larger display and now to answer
our main question who should upgrade to
the series 7 and i think that if you
have a series 6 you definitely shouldn't
upgrade the differences are very minor
unless you really care about faster
charging those are small differences and
even with the series 5 the differences
between the 5 and the 6 weren't that
great they were still bigger than the
differences from the 6 to the 7 so i
wouldn't update now if you're somebody
that has a series 4 apple watch that
doesn't have an always on display and
you're finally ready for that or the
other differences that were there then
maybe i would upgrade to the series
seven but it's still not a huge
difference and then for those of you
guys that have a series three or an
earlier one at this point i would say
yes definitely upgrade the differences
are going to be vast very noticeable you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comments section below we have links
to all these apple watches the deals
that come along now that the series 7 is
out there's still old stock of the
series six and five that are discounted
if you guys want to get those so go
ahead and check that out go ahead and
click above to subscribe to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
we would definitely appreciate it check
out one of those great videos right over
there this has been max and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]